where is my where is anything where is
it am I live am I streaming am I doing
anything is can anything work at all
ever can I
uh
hello
am I here
what am I here is it stable now is this
happening it says excellent am I alive
am I here
God
I I swear I swear
I swear all I've ever wanted all I've
ever wanted in life is to have a stable
fast internet connection that's all I've
ever wanted in my entire life that is
literally
all life wanted
for as long as I've been alive I have
only ever wanted a fast good internet
and yet I don't have it I don't have
that I somehow don't have that I don't
have it and I don't understand why
am I back am I am I back am I back oh
yeah my back
why in [ __ ] 2022
I I am a professional a professional
internet content creator I'm a
professional I do this for a living and
it's not for lack of trying it's not for
a lack of trying I have been in trying
so [ __ ] desperately I've been trying
so [ __ ] desperately to get to a
situation where I can have good stable
internet I've tried everything I've
tried everything I could write
everything I can possibly try I've tried
everything
and yet I am still stuck with
[ __ ] cable internet I'm still
[ __ ] stuck I swear I would pay any
amount of money to dig a goddamn
fiber line to where I am but it's not
possible and and it's it's also just
like why have I never been in one place
in all of my entire life that has had
fiber internet I have not once in my
goddamn life had it except for a tiny
moment when I was in an apartment and it
was just a temporary place I had it for
a brief [ __ ] Shining Moment and I
still to this day do not have good
internet
foreign
I don't
get it I've been doing this for over 10
[ __ ] years
after 10 years
I cannot
calm down I am back I'm like oh I'm
ready because I was in at my mom's house
where there's shitty cable internet and
no option for fiber that's what I lived
with and that my my stepmom's house
where it's just it's been a shitty cable
connection with no option for fiber
there is fiber internet in Cincinnati
where I grew up I didn't have it there
is fiber in L.A all over the place
there's so many different places in LA
with fiber I've never [ __ ] had it I
don't understand why I don't understand
how I don't understand anything about it
how it's impossible that I can't have it
and it's just like it's just like
[ __ ] you don't deserve it it's just
that's what they're telling me is that
it's the audio how is it bad how is any
of this wrong
oh
is there a problem with the audio
is there a problem with the audios is
there a problem
with the
would that be a problem
don't tell me that if there would be
enough not be the audio is fine good
they have limited our Liars Among Us
which is another problem
because if the audio is fine then that
means that we're there this child is
full of liars
and you know what we have to do with the
Liars we have to root them out we have
to root out the liars
anyway
I'm mad I'm angry and you know what I'm
fine with being angry I'm tired of
putting up with this [ __ ] I'm tired
I'm tired of it I'm so tired of it I'm
tired of it
I'm tired
of just always always because this is
I'm not exaggerating I don't know why
that's turned like that how did is that
someone rotate it when I was pounding
how did that happen
it's very strange
I'm just tired of it I'm tired of like
not having good internet how how how and
it's it's there's multiple problems with
it it's like it's so many things
where there's just the possibility of it
being good
and it's not good
right it's it's possible that it's good
and it's not good why are things like
with
with
Premiere right I was editing an entire
TV show I was editing an entire TV show
I don't believe any of you I don't
believe any of you I don't believe any
of you I don't believe none of you
you're all liars there are liars in this
stream there are liars in this stream
and I will not tolerate the Liars it is
Liars you think that my audience bad I
know my audience good because my audio
wouldn't betray me like that
no no no no my audio Works you're all
liars and you've heard your law you're
lying to me you're lying to me no I
refuse to believe it
here's here's a test if you can hear me
type e
H you can hear me type eh
yeah if you could hear me type e
h
wait a minute if you can hear me type e
lies the lies
is the lies I caught you red-handed
kind of you Liars you Liars you've never
didn't lie to me anyway
God it's it's so frustrating like
Premiere I was ahead
it's fine don't worry about it I was
editing and Premiere kept crashing
and I just you know I don't get it when
I started
doing YouTube
when I started doing YouTube
there was no way
to
understand
the idea that it would just get worse
with Premiere like it would just get
worse how
would it get worse
I did
I I don't want your Super Chat and I
know why it's hard
shush
shush
I'm not talking about that right now
I've moved on to other things to be
pissed about right I just don't get
Premiere just keeps getting worse and
I'm trying to do more with it admittedly
but I'm not doing any more than the
people that use it to edit movies which
they do they use it to edit movies all
the time in a professional capacity they
use this software and yet it gets worse
and people tolerate it I have the same
internet connection that I had 20 years
ago and people tolerate it
look at how do people tolerate it how do
people possibly tolerate it how could
people possibly tolerate it there's no
reason for people to tolerate it
right there's absolutely no reason
so
there's another thing that I'm pissed
about why is it hard
get people to understand that people
need upload speed
uploading
uploading would be ideal at this
juncture
laughs
anyway hair tutorial hair tutorial uh
I don't know
I don't know what I did
what am I clicking with something
clicking oh God I hope not
are you having a stroke I don't know at
this point I have no unders I have no
understanding what's true and what's not
true
hello
oh my bad
hello
I was going to play Oxygen not included
again hello hi okay I'm here
oh
good God this is awful this is awful
this is my welcome back
stream by the way how does this keep
anyway
uh where did people lose me
where did people lose me
okay good good
everything's probably fine I'm gonna
operate under the assumption that
everything's fine I'm gonna operate on
the Assumption your audio was very high
oh man
no I I just it really does it gets on my
nerves it does it gets on my nerves
because like I I as much as I joke about
like oh I'm a professional streamer I
don't know why like
I should at least be able to rely on my
dream I still have to hit my computer
guys did you know that I have to
physically hit my computer to get it to
stop making noise
I
am not joking
I physically hit my computer to get it
to shut up that that's my life that's my
life is like that why is everything so
hard why is everything so hard
why is everything so hard no I don't hit
it because I want to hit it because I'm
angry at it no it literally it makes
noise it physically makes noise
I don't know
it's hard it's hard to do anything it's
just it gets harder why does it get
harder why do things get worse why why
does why does things get worse this is a
glorious capitalism
why is it still a pain in the ass to
keep medications why is that still a
pain in the ass
what I'm good everybody I'm good
I didn't know if you thought I was not
good but I'm very good
no I'm fine
I'm fine I'm good
capitalism I'm not abusing my computer
look my computer wants to be my
computer's asking for it
shut up shut up shut up
see it's fine it's just I I sometimes
you gotta hit it sometimes you gotta hit
my computer
that's what it does and it'll shut up so
that's what it is look hey whoa
everybody
shut up
no it's just like that's not how
computers work it is exactly how my
computer works
it is 100 how my computer works it I do
that it do that thing it do that
man this has been a tumultuous
you guys know the definition of
tumultuous
disbanded tumultuous time coming back in
this stream
I feel like
I feel like we've we've we've overlooked
the things that we used to really take
for granted you know what I mean take
for granted
and I I understand that I understand
that a lot I understand that
but I want you all to make a solemn oath
right now everyone make us almost I mean
it pay attention hey stop eating ice
cream
pay attention look me look at me look at
me look at me you're not looking at me
look at me we're gonna make an oath here
together
okay it's time for Solomon though with
time but you didn't think you were gonna
make another look at me look at me hey
hey look at me
they didn't think you were gonna make a
solemn oath tonight but we're gonna make
a solemn oath together okay
all right
there's only a few months left well
actually less it's only a month and a
couple weeks left until the end of this
year and 2022 will be all behind us all
the turmoil
tribulations will be gone and then we'll
have 2023 and you know what 2023 is
going to bring new Horrors the likes of
we look at me hey don't look away don't
go introspective like all right don't
look at me look at me look at me
we only got a few weeks left until the
end of this year okay so we're gonna
make a solemn oath
now we're gonna stick together on this
okay that's the oath we're gonna make
thick and thin here
look I know it's not going to be easy
sometimes I'm going to go on a rampage
I'm going to go on a rant I'm going to
get angry
that's it for uh sorry I almost got this
right look at me look at me so let's
make the oath right now hold up your
hand
and this is actually my right hand I
know it looks like it might be my left
hand it's not the camera's flipped
hold up
this is my left I'll hold up both hands
okay just in case it's too confusing and
I don't have enough time for this there
is time of course there's time
I Deuce repeat after me I do saw look at
me I do solemnly swear
to stand by my fellow enabler
in support and opposition
of the entity known as Markiplier
we will be truthful
we will roll our eyes when necessary and
we will mock those who intend to mock Us
in return
but through thick and thin
I will stand by
and together
we will make it to 2023.
okay
I need repetitions of that so please
repeat that
I don't think that's how O's or finished
but that is what it is is this is cult
someone just asked if this was a cult
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
oh boy oh boy we're about to shift the
mood everybody get ready we're about to
shift
we're about to shift
we're shifting right now
we're shifting into a different mode
look at me listen to me listen to me
very carefully
the journey with which we are about to
Embark is different than that was which
originally prescribed but that was
prescribed in a different stream
apparently because that stream is gone
stream's not here not anymore
we don't need to worry about what came
before because we only have what's ahead
of us
to look forward to
and let me tell you something what's
ahead of us is something that is going
to change the fabric of our reality
because it changed the fabric of my own
so many years ago
and I think the mood calls for a
different experience one that we may not
have been
prepared for but
I think
the only thing we'll ever need
[Music]
do you know what we're about to do the
journey with which we are about to
Embark you guys swear to know is where
you didn't sworn you sweared an oath
it's coming
I think you do anyway
let's see let's see if you do
there it is
okay
because I'm in that kind of a mood right
now I'm I'm in I'm in this mood I am in
this mood
I'm I'm in the look oxygen not included
I thought it was gonna happen and then
look the mood shifted you got to be
adaptable you gotta roll with the things
you gotta do what you have to do okay
and I have to do this
because there's no other way
and I I'm a different person than I was
then I think anyway
I still got it
oh
I had forgotten
uh
we're feeling more intense than stuff oh
God this voice again you deleted your
homework the day before it was due as I
have or if you left your wallet at home
and you have to go back after spending
an hour
if you want some money at the casino and
then put all your winnings on red but it
came up black
if you've got your best shirt dry
cleaned before a wedding and then
immediately dropped food on it
if you want an argument with a friend
and then later discovered that they just
returned to their original View
starting over is harder than starting up
if you're not ready for that like if
you've already had a bad day then what
you're about to go through might be too
much feel free to go away and come back
I'll be here
[Music]
all right oh boy thanks for coming with
me on this trip oh boy I'll understand
if you have to take a break at any point
shut up just find a safe place to start
I don't know if I can listen to him
don't worry I'll save your progress
always even your mistakes
I don't know if I can listen to him
this game is a homage to a free game
that came out in 2002
sexy hiking
the author of that game was Jesuit a
mysterious
fine
listen
I don't think anybody needs anything
other than
the smooth sounds of my relaxed
voice
because I'm here to show you guys that
I've grown up
evolved from those Yonder years of Rage
fueled Madness I am
an evolved being
oh I'm an evolved being
yeah
and when it comes to
being an evolved being it's uh
[Music]
it means that
there's so much more
in life for us to see I know that how do
I get the subtitle go away there we go
now
we can relax now we can be at peace with
ourselves and with each other
being at peace means that we are at
peace
we are
stable in the inside our minds
right
so far be it for me that
make
a mountain out of a mole hill
God
I don't remember it controlling like
this I don't wasn't there a different
use trackpad tuning what does that do
oh
God don't
oh God don't do that
anyway
we are here to enjoy a little bit of
peace and quiet
nice uh somber experience that
really brings us all together we made a
solemn oath you and I a solemn oath
a solemn oath that can't be broken not
by anybody man or beast and so when you
make an oath like that you just know
how is that happening you know
that everything's gonna be okay
because you have
your oath brother and or sister your
oath sibling that's what we are to each
other we're oath siblings here
and as oath siblings we have a
responsibility to each other
so
oh
oh my God
oh
yes yes oh yes yes yes yes oh I'm stuck
oh I'm gonna be stuck no I'm not no I'm
not
watch this
yeah
yeah
yes yes
the power of the oath shines through yes
it does intense
yes it is
what have you missed oh you missed the
oath if you weren't here for the oath
you wouldn't understand the kind of bond
that we now share with each other
we are oath siblings through and through
now and forever
it's like the body system in a way you
know what I mean it's like the buddy
system yes yes
it's like the buddy system
no no none of that none of that
no
no
what are you doing oh sibling no no no
it's it's that no no no it's um
that's that's uh not it actually if you
that's actually not it so don't
uh maybe
it's more like you know
it's more like a cult it but it's not a
cult I'm not saying this is a cult but
it's it's
kind it's kind of like that more than
whatever you were doing
so I don't know what's going on listen
listen
everyone just hold on this is gonna get
wild not like that but you know it's
gonna get a little a little crazy
you think this guy would be good at FNAF
well you would be very right about that
it's actually funny that you mentioned
it I I am
incredibly good at FNAF
some would say almost kingly Lord leave
and my skill at the FNAF
there's many of them many uh people a
usurper if you will that would challenge
my authority but none may claim the
throne
yeah
I don't know why it sounds like I'm
trying to deep throat my microphone I'm
not I'm not
oh
oh that's not good
this is not ideal
but that's ideal yes
yes can I do the shortcut
can I do this Shorty could
oh yes
yeah I know I'm pretty good at streaming
maybe someone should award me with a
Fiber Optic internet connection but you
know I know that's earned I'm well aware
of it's earning is there what's over
here
is there anything over here oh you can't
even get up there never mind
yeah this is pretty good oh
I know there's a shortcut but I've never
been able to do it because I've never
been able to swing swung hard enough to
be able to get high enough
[Music]
yeah no there's no way
there's there's absolutely no way
yes yes we're not a cult that's not this
is
no no no no no no
that's not what it is we're gonna see
another chair fly that was the old me
that was the more immature me the one
that was not prepared for the
responsibilities that life oh God
had to offer yeah that's how I knew
that's how I do oh oath sibling
whoop
s
oh
both siblings unite
this oh God
oh God
did you know that in the link in the
description below is a link to my mom's
documentary you only have 24 hours
left to watch it it's now ten dollars
instead of fifteen last job
oh no oh hello hey what's up how's it
going everybody welcome to this if
you're just joining us here why don't
you smash that like button why don't you
smash it
push that like button and uh whale on
the Subscribe and then show unrelenting
hatred onto the Bell icon so that you
always know when I'm oh
foreign
[Music]
so that you always know when there's
going to be a hot fresh upload ready for
you
I don't know what's happening everybody
I this this stream really took a turn
but we're here
and I I feel like I'm compelled to go
forward even though I really don't want
to it's amazing that I still somehow
have a little bit of the muscle memory
that I had before uh to remember how to
play
that's not good
but
um yeah this stream really took a turn
if you weren't here before this is
actually the
oh
no I was there
[Music]
oh
okay listen everybody
you buy the documentary you've been here
for years and you're not going anywhere
now that's another that's an oath
sibling listen if you guys weren't here
for the oath you guys missed out the
oath isn't happening again but those
that were here near the true oath
siblings you can say
you were here
oh God
here we go
oh no
I don't remember how to do this I don't
remember how to do this part I do not
remember at all
I don't remember at all
I think I'd dangle out and then push
[Music]
that's what we call skill
now that's what we call skill everybody
you ever seen skill this magnitude
before
don't be intimidated by the sheer side
skill
oh the skill
God the Pixel Perfect skill
oh let's kill this kill
the skill oh that skill
that is
now let me tell you one again
I'm just killed
stop moaning look if you don't know the
difference between
gaming and moaning and Skilling
You couldn't possibly comprehend the
magnitude of the oath that was made so
why don't you
I'll get to the point where I'm like
swallowing my microphone
look I don't know guys I don't even know
how I got here I like blinked I raged
out and suddenly I'm streaming playing
getting over it I don't know what
happened between A and B but I'm here
now and my skilled demands that I
continue oh wow oh baby a triple skill
Ah that's how you do that's how you do
oh that's how you do look I need more
mouse pad oh God the skill the freaking
skill
the ungodly ungodly unrelent no no the
skill
oh no no no no yes the skill will win
God the skill wins every time oh
[Music]
the skill
oh
[Music]
hey
oh
how oh oh
[Music]
the skill
my God this is what your Oaths have done
to me the amount of power the skill that
you've granted me oh man if only you
knew you had this power within you all
along and now
and now
and now
and now
you will see
I remember now this orange Must Die
oh this is where I'm gonna oh God ah man
oh no oh
it's so finicky sometimes I don't know
why oh God I can't do it oh
the orange needed to Die the orange
needed to Die the orange messed me up
before I remember
the orange messed me up I can't deal
with the orange the orange had to die if
you don't understand why the orange had
to die it's not a man it don't are you
questioning my skill I could have done
it with the orange there but the orange
disrespected my skill it's not that my
skill couldn't overcome the orange it's
that it disrespected
my skill
you understand you understand
yeah right
good
oh holy [ __ ]
oh
oh
oh
no my skill someone broke their oath oh
God
someone broke the oh oh no
how could you do that
who did it please who broke the oath my
skill left me
oh who did it who broke the oath don't
it was the orange
it was the orange
the orange did this to me as I see now
you know why the orange Must Die
but the orange didn't die then dude
huh
the orange must die we all know it to be
true
we all understand this we understand
we need this oh we need it to
earth
oh oh no no no no no
[Applause]
who did it
who broke the oath
I'm
I just wanna know who it was so I can
never
what
I hear there are
those among you that
no longer believe in the oath you've
decided with
a mere Tangerine there's no orange is
not worthy of being called an orange no
Cult of the orange that is a Fool's name
you let your soul rot it's like the
peels of the orange
I'm not upset even the most Wayward of
you
so-called oath siblings
still be redeemed
you can still be
forgiven but it will take a lot to
forgive such
transgressions
you broke oh I see
orange siblings you think that's funny
you think that's funny do you you think
that's funny
go
oh orange siblings oh good to great
that's really really hilarious because
if it wasn't just a joke which I know it
is I know it's just a fun joke
one would think that it would be a cause
for
opponent
I need to know right now I need to know
right now hold on I need to know right
now I need to know
I need to know I'm putting a pole there
you tell me right now you tell me right
now you tell me right now you tell me
right now
you tell me right now if I
am there good good
oh wow
let's see yeah
okay
yeah sure of course
after all I've done for you after all
I've done for everyone here after all
the O's that we make we know that there
are oath Breakers here holy [ __ ]
you think that you are funny you think
this is just like a fun game
no the
you've made your peace I actually do
know who answers what in those polls I
see it down to the exact user I see
everything
everything you've ever done every poll
you've ever voted in if I click on your
name I know your entire chat history I
know every word you've uttered I know
everything
I know everything
I will not only make those who
decide to decide
with the orange
hey I will see which one of you are
really loyal
I can't do it anymore
I can't do it anymore why can't I do it
oh no why
this is oh
I can't do it I did oh it is so good my
first time back and now I'm just oh I
can't do it anymore
oh
man oh man oh man
[Music]
oh man guys oh man
oh man guys
I'm fine I'm fine this is all good that
was a test you think that I'm just like
a oh man you think that I'm just a heap
of nothingness oh that I'm gonna I'm
gonna fall apart at the oh most deepest
inconvenience that's not who I am that's
not who I is that's not who I is that's
not like yeah
oh oh
oh
the trick is and there there this is
coming from an expert
it's a new account my control is broken
I have a gold
Ron but
yes yes
let's see I was fooling you all
the thinking I was terrible when in
reality here I am
truly something to behold watch this
watch this this is what they call the
shorty cut
shorty cut
oh
God
[Music]
going down lord feeling bad I'm Going
Down The Road Feeling Bad
going down
[Music]
thank you
symptoms of one plan
[Music]
down in the jail on my knees
[Music]
away
[Music]
they feed me on corn bread and cheese
[Music]
this away
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes the skills back yes that's what the
power of the Believers the Believers who
really truly know where the skill comes
from
oh no oh yeah there we go
that's what I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about
yep
all right now that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking about
now listen now
yep oh yeah
the Orange
is no more the Orange
is Dead
We are so
far beyond that
hold on everybody hold on hold on
hold on
hold on everybody
hold on
hold on everyone
oh
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay
[Laughter]
okay okay
[Music]
oh
oh
it's fine
oh
oh
[Music]
whoops
[Music]
why does that happen in pain
s
why does that happen in pears
in pain
s
oh
it happens in
hairs
why why would that happen in
pairs what that happened last time too
it's just
that doesn't make sense
how does that make sense it doesn't
it doesn't make sense that's the thing
about it
oh
but God
foreign
[Music]
hmm
anywho
had a little uh moment there but I'm
back we're here again with another
episode of getting over it with Bennett
foddy one of my favorite games of recent
years it really does show that there is
no God it really does prove that it's
just uh
Universe of misery and Decay you know
there's only cruelty but that's what we
love about it we love the fact that it
when you go into it it's a singularly
common experience everyone knows it you
know there's only rage and suffering and
uh
I've grown numb to it over so long of
suffering you know
even hell can grow boring at times but
uh you know sometimes I just like to
crack it open again and just see see
what I was missing before and I was
missing a lot and and in all honesty you
know you start to suffer for so long
you miss it a little bit you can miss it
it's it's uh intoxicating it's addictive
and you you find yourself drawn back
into it which is why it's one of my
favorite games of all time easily easily
uh
top uh top 200 for sure
without a doubt without doubt without a
doubt
and uh when you do have an opportunity
to play it again there's um
well I mean there's really no better way
than starting over at the beginning
that's just how it goes
so uh thank you all you oathies out
there well
oh
all of you guys who uh kept your promise
unlike those oath Breakers we don't name
names here but even in Hell there are
those with no honor
we don't talk about them but what we do
talk about is our indomitable will the
perseverance that we have and we know
that we are
here together in this moment United in
our common understanding of how
good this game is and how much we love
it and how much we would do anything for
it
and we would do anything for our oath
siblings here
what
[Music]
I've been friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
reason why I cry for me
[Music]
I
[Music]
that made me what I am
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
words to live by words to remember
[Music]
I left my mother standing in the door I
think we've all been there before
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
almost
[Music]
this is how we're done to do it
so we're gonna do it everybody oh my God
every time I say something and I look
over at Chad I I and
every time every time I I didn't every
time I think I say the word chat things
go wrong
that's what I've discovered
so I'll call I'll just say y'all
young just sit back and appreciate
what's about to happen the truest show
of skill
world has ever seen
now that's called skill Now That's What
I Call skill 18.
that skill right there let's go
skill skill skill skill skill skill man
you know I turned on trackpad settings
because it's just like the the way it
was moving wasn't right I I think I
remember it I turned that on before
but man
who would beat this on a trackpad that's
what I don't know who would beat this on
a trackpad
oh the skill I know I know calm yourself
it's still no not November so really I
know this
saved it saved it somehow
why was it bouncing
why was it bouncing why
why was it bouncing
why why did it bounce
Why did Why was it bouncing why was it
bouncing
why was it bouncing
it was just bouncing but why
why was it bouncing
I don't get that it was bouncing why was
it bouncing
why was it bouncing whoa
what what happened what what was that
what what it's the trackpad settings
it's betraying me just like I knew it
would
I swear
nope
oh God
oh
come on
that's pretty good
anyway if we could not bounce that would
be ideal
oh God I'm in trouble I'm in trouble I'm
in trouble I'm in trouble I'm in trouble
I'm not in trouble
turns out I'm glad I'm in trouble I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble I'm in trouble
I'm not in trouble
I'm just fine
thanks for asking
there we go
okay yeah the skill is burning out of
your eyes oh that's not the only thing
that's going to be burning out of your
eyes
it's your eyes are gonna be burning out
of your eyes and ask questions you don't
you don't still
trust me
I know what I'm doing
what
yep
no it's bouncing again it's doing the
bouncing thing
no no it's it's oh oh
sorry money
it why is it bouncing why is it bouncing
it should not be bouncing it shouldn't
be bouncing why would it be bouncing why
is it bouncing I don't get it I don't
understand
why would it be bouncing
oh
why would it be bouncing it doesn't make
any sense why would it be bouncing
it shouldn't be bouncing it wouldn't be
bouncing it couldn't be bouncing if it
could just stop bouncing for a second
then everything would be fine but it
chooses to be bouncy why I don't really
know I don't understand the Bell oh it's
fine there was a table there all along I
didn't need to be so scared of that not
that I was but if it could just be
don't not bouncy stable
oh my God are you kidding oh
speed run time here we go this is called
Pro moves 100 run uh golden cauldron
level Goal Golden cauldron excellent
skill all the time uh money back
guarantee of skill prescribed from your
doctor straight to you speedrun time
speedrun time speed run time
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know what time it is everybody wow
[Music]
oh
foreign
might be the last night you can see my
mom's documentary link is in the
description prices dropped
sound 10 bucks watch it it's very good
last day
no I'm gonna go I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go
it's been a tumultuous evening
those of you who did not break your oath
you are the real ones
may your to quote something I learned
from Ethan today
may your RIS be unstoppable
forevermore
unflappable
given the old Razzle Dazzle or something
like that I don't know
I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go links in the
description
I'm gonna go Link in the last chance
Last Chance
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go goodbye